-That's right, everybody.
Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here. Big show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Big show tonight.
I'm so excited about this.
Keith Richards
is my guest tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I am such a huge fan.
I went up to Keith backstage,
I told him, "You are my hero.
The Stones are the greatest
rock 'n' roll band ever,"
and I'll never, never forget
what Keith told me.
He said...
[ Mumbling quietly ]
[ Laughter ]
It was so heartfelt.
Yeah, I love it.
I'm so glad Keith is here,
actually.
It makes me so happy
because it's rained now
seven weekends in a row here
in New York City.
Everything is soaked.
The rain is so bad that today,
on my way into work,
I saw a squirrel rubbing
talcum powder on his nuts.
And I go, "That's when it's..."
[ Laughter ]
-Acorns?
-Well, guys, some big news.
Last night, President Biden gave
a national prime-time address
about what's happening
in Israel and Ukraine.
And people are saying it's the
best speech he's ever given.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
Yeah, this might have been
Biden's best speech
since he opened for Lincoln
at Gettysburg.
They --
-Oy!
-That's right.
Biden proved two
very important things
to the world --
that we will stand
with our allies
and that he can stay
awake past 8:00 p.m.
That's -- that's it.
He did it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
Biden's speech pre-empted
all the network's
regular programming,
so people tuning in were like,
"This is the most boring episode
of 'The Golden Bachelor' yet."
[ Laughter ]
Some more news
from Washington.
After losing the speaker vote
for the third time this week --
the third time, yeah --
Congressman Jim Jordan
is no longer in the running
for speaker of the House.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, he was never
in the running.
Now he's officially
not in the running.
But get this --
the temporary speaker,
Congressman Patrick McHenry,
is around 5'5", okay?
And some people noticed
that he seemed
to swap out the speaker's chair
to make himself look taller.
Here's the old chair.
You see this? Yeah.
Now, this is real.
Here's the new one.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I thought this was nice.
They also added a set
of those dog steps
so we can reach the podium.
I thought that was nice.
Guys, I read that
former president Trump
was just fined $5,000
for violating a gag order
in his New York
civil fraud trial.
Even more concerning,
Trump was like, "I'm ruined!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Muted cymbal crash ]
Guys, some business news.
Today, Spirit Airlines
canceled dozens of flights
to perform a "necessary"
inspection of the planes.
[ Laughter ]
So, until now, I guess
they considered
inspections optional?
Is that -- "Necessary?"
I'm not sure
what's more stressful --
being on one of the flights
that was canceled
or one of the flights
that wasn't.
You're like, "Wait."
Honestly, I always thought
a Spirit inspection
was just a guy coming out
and kicking the tires
like -- [ Inhales sharply ] --
"It's good."
[ Laughter ]
"Fly."
Well, listen to this.
After an FDA panel found
that an ingredient in cold
medicines like Mucinex, NyQuil,
and Sudafed
doesn't actually work,
CVS announced
that they are pulling
some of the medicines
from their shelves.
Yep, so now Sudafed's
entire demographic
is people making meth.
[ Laughter ]
That's it.
Well, this is going viral.
[ Laughter continues ]
"Can I get a key to the --
Yeah."
This is going viral.
An international student
was applying for colleges
in the U.S.
and wanted to go
to the University of Miami
to be near the beach,
but she accidentally
enrolled in Miami, Ohio.
[ Laughter, audience groans ]
-Oh.
-Yeah.
She also meant
to apply to Brown,
but now she has a job at UPS.
-Oh.
[ Laughter, audience groans ]
[ Scattered applause ]
So it's like -- Yeah.
[ Rimshot ]
[ Applause ]
And finally, a new study found
that sitting in a hot tub
for 30 minutes
has the same health benefits
as going for a run.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That -- That is according
to the new head of the CDC,
Dr. Tommy Bahama.
We have a great show.
Give it up for The Roots,
ladies and gentlemen!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wh-a-a-a-a-at?!
"Hackney Diamonds" is out now.
The new Rolling Stones
album is out now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And he is on our show tonight.
Last night,
I was very, very lucky.
I got invited to the --
to a secret show, actually.
I went to the album --
It was the album --
What do they call it?
-Release.
-A release party.
I go, "Great. I'll go to see
the album release party to see,
you know, Mick and Ronnie
and Keith are there."
I go, "Great."
I go, "Are they playing?"
They go, "No, no, no, no, no.
No, it's just
an album release party."
"Okay, cool."
I go, "Well, that's fine.
I'll just go."
And then I saw you,
and you go -- you're D.J.'ing.
-Yeah.
-And you're there, so I go,
"Oh, cool. That'll be fun.
I'll see Quest.
It'll be fun to go out there."
I go in there.
It's a tiny club.
Tiny.
Where was it? Racket?
-Racket.
-On 16th Street, I remember.
It's a beautiful club
but small.
But there's instruments
on stage.
-Oh.
-Ooh.
-There's a drum set.
There's guitars.
There's a microphone.
I go, "Uh-oh. I think
something's gonna go down."
All of a sudden,
the lights go out.
Questlove's
not D.J.'ing anymore.
He's sitting where I'm sitting.
I go, "Dude, what's happening?"
You're like, "Oh, yeah,
it's about to go down."
They come out,
and it's almost like
♪ Shadow, shadow ♪
I was like, "What?"
It was unbelievable.
I was -- honestly, I think --
I'm not kidding.
I don't want to complain.
I think I was too close.
-Yeah.
-Do you think we were too close?
-That'll never happen
in our lifetime again.
-I was too close to the Stones.
-Wow.
-I think it was
a little distracting.
-Like, how close?
-Well, like,
say I'm here, right?
This is me.
-Right.
-And he's like --
And he's like, "Go away,
go away, go away.
[ Gibberish ]
"Go, go! Stop! Go!
Move out of the way!"
Like, he couldn't --
I was ruining his mojo.
Mick was out
doing his thing, and...
And I was just like --
I was just, like,
sitting, like...
I was getting --
I was getting a lap dance
from Mick Jagger.
I don't do that.
-Yeah.
-I don't do that.
But it happened last night.
It was unbelievable.
And they came out, and they just
showed everybody how you do it,
which is like, no tricks,
no computers, no anything.
"Give me a guitar,
give me a microphone.
I'm gonna show you
how to rock out."
And they destroyed.
They were so great.
And at the end, they finish,
and they -- they leave.
And, you know, I don't know
if there's such a thing
as encores anymore.
Not really, right?
You kind of know
they're coming out for one more.
They have to.
Right?
The lights turn on,
and you go -- we go home.
Back in the day,
you have to go, "One more..."
They don't do that anymore.
I'm fine with that.
So I'm playing the game.
I go, "Yeah,"
but I can --
I can see the lights aren't on,
so they're gonna come out
for one more.
Not only do they come out
for one more,
Lady Gaga comes out
with The Rolling Stones.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, all-timer performance.
-Yes.
-All-timer performance.
-Yeah.
-Everybody --
Keith was on fire.
Literally.
Someone lit him on fire.
He was like -- he just played --
He was awesome.
Ronnie Wood and Gaga
just went for it.
Rock 'n' roll.
It was unbelievable.
All the new songs
they played, it's great.
Anyways, "Hackney Diamonds"
is out officially today.
[ Cheers and applause ]
On our show.
He is one of the greatest
guitarists of all time
in one of the greatest
bands of all time,
The Rolling Stones.
New album, "Hackney Diamonds,"
is out now.
He is here with us tonight.
Keith Richards is on the show
tonight, so that'll be fun.
That'll be cool to see, Keith.
That'll be great.
But we'll get to Keith...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Not now. Later.
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
♪♪
-That was a walk-by.
-Not now.
-Yeah.
-He will be on the show,
but not -- not yet.
[ Laughter ]
How cool is that dude
right there?
He just --
you know, just walk out.
[ Applause ]
He doesn't care.
He's Keith Richards.
He does what he wants.
[ Laughter ]
Plus, they are
Grammy-winning artists
who have sold over
45 million albums combined.
Their new album,
"Welcome 2 ColleGrove,"
comes out November 17th,
2 Chainz and Lil Wayne
are here tonight.
We're going to talk to them,
and then they're performing
later in the show.
It's a big show tonight.
2 Chainz and Lil Wayne.
Guys, today is Friday,
and that's usually
when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
I check my inbox,
I return some e-mails,
and, of course,
I send out Thank You Notes.
I like to write out
Thank You Notes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Don't we do --
I'd like to write out some
weekly Thank You Notes
right now for you guys.
Do you guys mind
if I write some out tonight?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I appreciate it!
James, can I get some Thank
You Note writing music, please?
♪♪
Wow.
-He's not in his wig.
-Yeah, he's in a good mood.
[ Laughter ]
I like his shirt.
-Yeah. It's classy.
-Yeah, it's like --
It's like a rust color.
-Yeah. Let's see it again.
-Yeah.
That's beautiful, man.
He's called "Mr. Autumn."
-Yeah.
Mr. Autumn, they call him. Yeah.
-That's right.
[ Laughter ]
-His shirts change
like the leaves.
-Yeah.
-It's a beautiful thing.
-Only once a year.
-Yeah. Yeah.
That's the same shirt he wore --
-Same shirt he wore last autumn.
-It just progressively
gets filthy.
-It's from the fall collection.
-Yeah. Until it falls off.
-Yeah.
-And then he's shirtless.
And then he shirtless.
-Get threadbare until it falls.
And then we know
the times have changed.
You know what I mean?
-That's the only way I know
that I'm alive, is to
see him change his clothes.
It's beautiful to see you.
James from The Roots
right there.
James, can I get some
Thank You Note writing music?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Wow. He's an animatronic.
-Wow.
-He's, like, animatronic.
-It's like he's in
the Chuck E. Cheese band.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, hay rides,
for letting me know
what Uberpool would be like
in 1835.
You go, "Oh."
[ Applause ]
"Hop on the back!"
-"Have a seat!"
-"Hay!"
-[Singsong voice] "Hay!"
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you, Adirondack chairs,
for looking like the skeleton
of a La-Z-Boy.
-Ooh!
-Spooky. Spooky.
-Hallow-e-e-een!
-Hallow-e-e-e-een!
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Thank you, space bar,
for being the manspreader
of the keyboard.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
"How much space you need?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa."
-"We got it."
-"We got it.
Gosh. Sit normal, bud."
Oh, this is a good one.
♪♪
Thank you, Las Vegas Aces owner
Mark Davis,
for ending the WNBA season
with a bangs.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Come on.
-He did a good job.
-That's a good one.
-Yeah.
-He did a great job.
He ended with a bangs.
Yeah.
♪♪
Thank you, accidentally
breaking an olive-oil bottle
on the ground,
for making me go,
"You know what?
Let's just move."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I'm not cleaning this up."
-Yeah.
-"It's gonna take me four years
to clean that up."
-Them tiny slivers of glass
all day long.
-Let's look at other --
Let's get on Zillow.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, Jack-o'-lanterns,
for showing me
you don't need teeth
to be happy.
[ Laughter ]
-Aww.
-Happy. Happy pumpkin.
♪♪
Thank you,
"The Golden Bachelor."
You may not win any Emmys,
but you're definitely
taking home some Grammys.
Hey. There you have it.
[ Laughter ]
Those are some Thank You Notes.
We'll be right back
with Keith Richards!